les femmes entrepreneurs ont un nouvel
outil un nouvel appui pour faire croître
reconnaître leur entreprise le réseau
des femmes d'affaires du québec et la
caisse de dépôt et placement ont mis sur
pied une base de données la rs accus
plus c'est une plateforme qui va servir
à répertorier les entreprises à
propriété féminine québécoise favoriser
leur maillage avec de grandes sociétés
on en parle avec rénovation et les pdt
du réseau des femmes d'affaires du
québec merci d'être là modération
alors expliquez nous c'est quoi cet
outil comment ça fonctionne c'est une
communauté virtuelle
ça s'appelle le rif lac plus qu on dit
qui sert à connecter les entreprises à
propriété féminine avec les grandes
entreprises des services
d'approvisionnement des grandes
entreprises dans le but de donner des
contrats offerts l'entrepreneur donc un
grand répertoire et vous avez travaillé
de concert avec la caisse de dépôt entre
autres pourquoi ce partenaire là mais
c'est que l'an dernier on avait formé un
groupe de travail et les grandes y avait
c'est d'essayer la caisse de dépôt et
elle agropur et entre 14 14 15 g
entreprises comme ça et ce qui reste sur
têt dans ca devait nous on veut acheter
des entreprises qui appartiennent à des
femmes c'est juste qu'on ne sait pas où
les trouver on veut acheter où on veut
faire affaire vous faire afin c'est ça
on veut faire affaire avec des
entreprises à propriété féminine on ne
sait pas où les trouver alors la caisse
de dépôt qui était partenaire de cette
de cette initiative l'audi parfait je
vais investir et on va construire une
communauté virtuelle pour être capable
de relier ces deux entités de ce qui est
agréable c'est que la caisse de dépôt
était le partenaire financier mais
l'entreprise qui a réalisé toute cette
oeuvre là c'est une entreprises à
propriété féminine de québec innove ça
qui est spécialisée en transformation
numérique alors pour nous ça faisait
prêcher par l'exemple et là le
répertoire est opérationnel il est bâti
les montées est-ce que vous avez un
large éventail de participants de femmes
entrepreneurs qui se sont déjà inscrits
alors là on est à l'étape coquilles sur
le lancer mercredi d'
né dans le cas de la journée
internationale des femmes avec la bdc
est ce qu'on a fait c'est que on a mis à
la disposition le répertoire et
maintenant on est en pleine période
d'inscription et on prévoit d'ici la fin
d'année d'avoir à peu près 500
entreprises à propriété féminine qui
vont être inscrits et la prochaine étape
maintenant que robben quand le quand
leur répertoire
on sera mieux garni comment ça
fonctionne le maillage avec des
entreprises ce sont elles qui font appel
à vous comment ça fonctionne dans les
deux on a fait un pilote avec cinq
grandes entreprises qui ont été un peu
qu'ils ont été un peu nos cobayes entre
guillemets est ce que ça permet c'est
que la femme ça devient une une une
plateforme visuelle pour réelle avancée
alors sont toutes ces spécialités qu'est
ce qui a fait sa capacité qu est-ce qu
avant les produits services est-ce
qu'elle a des certifications quelconque
qui pourrait correspondre à des
adhérents le cv exactement un mini
plateforme à elle-même et la grande
entreprise je prends par exemple dans la
grosne mon entreprise dans
l'agroalimentaire et elle va aller
inscrire les mots clés est-ce qu'elle va
des produits sans gluten est ce qu a
vendu 2 dd des graines de quinoa ou peu
importe et l'intelligence artificielle
fait que quand une grande entreprise est
à la recherche de notes d'un produit ou
service quelqu'un va sur cette
communauté virtuelle là ils sont
capables d'entrer en train contact
ensemble et sont capables de valider et
l'intérêt et la capacité pour ensuite
penser à l'étape de la commande donc
puisque trampling si on veut pour les
entreprises à propriété féminine vous
attendez à des retombées concrètes pour
le chiffre d'affaires pour la visibilité
tout à fait parce que on a on s'est
quand même qu'au canada on a beaucoup
d'entreprises à propriété féminine
montana aussi beaucoup de petites qui
veut dire que chacune d'elles doit pas
nécessairement département développement
des affaires
alors ce que ça fait c'est que ça permet
à ces fables d'être visible ça leur père
d'avoir accès à des chaînes
d'approvisionnement qui sont souvent
très très difficile pour les grandes
entreprises vont elles ça leur permet de
diversifier leurs produits et d'avoir de
trouver des des fournisseurs nouveau
vous disiez qu'il y en avait beaucoup et
quand même dans le dernier classement
des 300 pme les plus importantes au
québec du journal les affaires y avait
seulement 8% des organisations de
détenus dirigées par des femmes comment
on explique ça encore en 2001
d'entrepreneuriat chez les femmes si ça
date pas de 200 ans
alors on est en faisant choisi aussi des
créneaux qui apporte moins d'employés
alors on a au canada 16 % des
entreprises qui sont détenues
majoritairement par des femmes ce qui
veut dire 51 pour sa d'actionnariat et
plus mais quand on le transposant noms
d'employés c'est moins de 5
alors on a quand même beaucoup de
petites alors on a un autre des grandes
mais c'est sûr que le pourcentage est
bas et c'est pour ça que des initiatives
comme ça permette de créer de la
richesse au féminin à un rythme plus
accéléré
vous avez donné un exemple avec
l'agroalimentaire est ce que il ya des
secteurs des industries dans lesquelles
les entreprises sont représentées par
des femmes sont plus importants mais 80%
au canada 80 % des entreprises qui sont
détenus par des femmes sont dans le
service oui alors c'est certain que en
nous notre initiative qui est
intéressant c'est que c'est autant dans
le service que dans la fabrication tous
secteurs confondus alors nous on ne
représente pas un secteur on représente
les femmes entrepreneurs puisque
français que ce genre de répertoire le
fait qu' on assure un encadrement un
accompagnement est le réseau des femmes
d'affaires du québec existe le plus
d'outils est ce que vous pensez que ça
va encourager une entrepreneuriaux
féminin énormément mais ça va surtout
encourager celles qui sont déjà sur
place donc assurer leur survie assurer
leur survie
je vous donne juste un exemple une une
de nos membres
décroché un seul contrat qui a permis de
faire jadis son entreprise de 350 5 % en
dix huit mois grâce à votre répertoire
ou une autre initié avec grâce à lui
initiatives connexes parfait avant le
répertoire il y avait nos cerveaux alors
les entreprises nous appelait pour dire
est ce que vous connaissez une
entreprise qui vend tel ou tel secteur
j'aurai besoin alors c'était un cerveau
de ce bo3 cerveau puis écrit on ajoute
le répertoire l'intelligence
artificielle madame nation vous avez à
revoir encore du prix sur la planche
oui mais c'est pour ça que c'était fait
un mois de l'âge il d'ailleurs je pense
qu'on remplace à s'améliorer un petit
peu plus à tous les jours merci d'avoir
été là nous fuit